why don't we give these a shot these are
I was interested by how challenging you
found them I intentionally made the loss
line a bit of a couple but the first
suit we should find out Lee you'll see
what I've been missing
I can tell you're number one now a lot
of us are sort of struggling to grapple
with with their branches where I
multiply everything by a number or do I
leave some bits up let me try and
explain because I just thought of what I
hope is a helpful wedding please let's
think about because it sounds like
that's your duty but you see that
numbers because we can deal with numbers
if I showed you something like this I
think we can all agree that that's true
now how does it work if we maintain the
equation but start to muck with it in
the same way that you have to muck with
this in order to solve it okay so an
example would be what if I wanted to
multiply by four okay now one of the
questions I got one
if I multiply by four do I multiply well
I get that the line inside that'll
become 4x over 4 but do I multiply one
of these or both of these give it one
which one so how does very work let me
define it go straight over here if I
multiply the right-hand side by 4 we
know that becomes 20 now if I only
multiply one of the objects over here by
4 what will happen let's just try this
one
please knows more about this now if I
just left the 2 and it were loud not
like triplets 12 is not true yeah if I
were to believe you must exist and also
multiply it by 4 and then it's true
does that make sense and this is very
closely related to but not the same as
this and this is where I think the
confusion arises
this is also true to agree but I'm going
to do this x 14 again
not particularly if I multiply the right
hand side it becomes 24 now look closely
there are two objects over here do I
multiply them both by four well watch
what happens if I multiply this one by
four
I'll get eight yeah
now if I want is by four as well it will
become 12 but eight times
not 24 8 10 12 is not 6
so in fact that tree they thought which
is green from there
these are multiplies birds or the other
one I could do it again I was play why
attentive suppose I said let's travel to
London to buy for and that's what gave
you eight what if I multiplied the three
is there I've done the right-hand side
let's change that three times four is 12
right what happens is to roll on why not
buy four result hello because 8 times 12
is we just ended right if I multiplied
that one then you don't multiply the
other little trick like here's the
question why over here and it's just
numbers right like you guys tell me
means right or it's wrong why on this
side join us to multiply both pieces by
4 or 4 3 whereas only here you actually
have to choose during this one or do
this one but if you do both you're kind
of stuff so the obvious difference is
the operation 20 right so addition am I
see the Superman
yeah
the obviously a difference is that
there's addition vegetable patient so
why then do I do it for this one but not
for this one is not the other way around
how are you going to remember the next
time oh look I've ever made it different
so therefore I want I both have in
science lab whatever number I choose
versus if I change that to a time
so I would suggest you to drink this
left-hand side over here two times three
it's really one object if six right so
when you multiply two times three by all
you have to do it one because it's one
object right whereas over here these two
guys are well and truly separate right
just like over here they are separate so
you have to multiply each one
independently otherwise you saw it
didn't work right if you want to figure
out in play and yes because you've got
to separate under I can't collect them
it anyway right so therefore you have to
treat them as separate so the after
multiply each one by four or whatever
Duncan chose if you're ever unsure just
you go with numbers right and see what
happens if you get something at the end
and you you're not sure about it where
you can substitute and see if it works
at 94 what's a better number to choose
to multiply by really I think you're
gonna have to watch what I do see which
is a big number
okay but it was that as the most common
a star which is 224 I think people look
at an equation and they choose to
multiply by that number will be bygones
I just want my terrifying I thought my
job just want you today with the power 7
times 8 times 4 is 324 I think in a
defining point often yes okay so you
don't need to multiply by a number that
is I mean you can if you want but you
don't have to one often normal need is
me taking
yeah 50 60 is fine we're looking for a
lowest common multiple in fact anything
that a code youtube for also Goods
issues so that we actually bought a
30-story what you multiply everything by
a banner number I'll just show you what
the next line D that I think you go to
work from there I think that's a hard
part this will become a box of that this
will become that and this will become
sequence y x right okay
that's what should my job so I get from
there I'm going to that's going to
become 24 I'm going to subtract it
across will give you negative 10x
and then you divide through by negative
/ yeah so let me write you if I have 56
Los Zetas and 256 lots of that and 56
watts oh yes you can see 56 divided by 7
trade 56 divided by 8 is 7 and 56
divided by 4 is 14 so that's where we
delicious okay um are we okay with this
one choosing this box number one
Sullivan much at question three question
three what actually do you think is
hotter the question because there's
something on this question right now is
the opposite of when you get given a
triangle with exactly one side exactly
another sign and exactly the included
angle you're like oh well these are the
three numbers I have to put in and you
can't it's hard to screw it up we're
here I've given you lots of information
and you actually have to pick and choose
which one you need and you can actually
get it wrong for example you compete you
side and then you can pick the able to
sort between them and then you'll get
the area of some other triangle along
people so just quickly look at on can
you residual again yes but look at the
number she came five times six point
five so we're going to this one and this
one right
so therefore the include English you get
it right yeah janelda
now you're working might be completely
different because this region already
quickens area you could have picked
instead of six point five and five
you could get six point five and ten
point seven like if you did that you'd
pick a different angle which one
included one which is forty now just
quickly unless you already business we
can go ahead and verify you put half a B
times C in with these sets of numbers
there I think you might actually get
something off by a decimal place you
like it just someone get like sixty
points you six equal year did it land on
16.1 we get it just fell down
yeah the reason why you get talking to
slightly different is because I've
actually rounded these numbers here
that's why I'm working
I had to work out what they actually
supposed to be after just making them
yes/no so it keep it be if I change the
question to be in you can still bother
just in this way the intention is a
mystery so I want to learn many things
about this if you remember this comes
actually from this is related to the
famous okay and the cycle looks like
this if you remember your population and
is actually a third one over here which
we we like we never really used informs
we're like two is enough okay but the
point is it works all the way around
every single version is adjusting food
products potential